***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.  This
text, document, or file is not
to be distributed or used in any
way that may violate copyright
law.
***
Captioner standing by...
PLAU
[ Applause ]
>> Okay. Does that make you
want to see the movie? Good! We
were a little worried that you
might have been a little too
scared...
[ Applause ]
you're not?
Well, let's give -- and I said
it as I came down the steps.
We have people watching us live
on Facebook and YouTube!
So can we give a big hello to
everybody watching?
[ Cheers and Applause ]
I think that they heard you. You
know where you're here.
Do KBROU you think the stage is
scarry enough?
Will it give you goose bumps?
All right! Well, I'm bringing in
a special lady who works at the
library, Ms. Lee Ann Potter.
Give her a hand!
[ Applause ]
Because she is going to
introduce our
special guest.
>> LEE ANN POTTER: Good
morning.
We are so excited that you are
here, and what a special treat
to have the librarian of
congress welcome you this
morning
È LEE ANN POTTER: Good morning.
We are so excited that you are
here, and what a special treat
to have the librarian of
congress welcome you this
morning.
I want to do a few special
shout-outs to you. I want to
recognize the students and
their teachers, as well as
chaperons who are here in our
library of congress today. And
if you will hold your applause
until the very end for
yourselves, that would be great.
From Washington dc, we welcome
students
from capitol hill Montessori
school.
Okay. One more time.
I'm going to read seven schools,
so we'll wait until the end and
chair. From St. Patrick's day
school, from plumber
elementary school, from capitol
hill --
from Mori elementary school.
Also, we have a school from
Maryland,
from hunting town, the Langley
school in
McClain, Virginia. And as Dr.
Hayden mentioned --
There are students also watching
us
-- [ whispering ]. It kind of
works.
We're also excited that students
are viewing the program this
morning on the library's website
as well as the library's YouTube
and Facebook channels. Later
today you guys are going to have
an opportunity to ask some
questions of
your own, and we also are
inviting students who are
watching the live
stream to send questions via
Twitter.
And you can use the hashtag
#goosebumps to ask your
question.
It is my pleasure this morning
to introduce you to our very
special author. R.L.
Stine is one of the best-selling
children's authors in history.
In July 1992,  scholastic
introduced the first
"Goosebumps" book.
Nearly 25 years later,
"Goosebumps" is one of the best
selling children's
series of all times with more
than 350 million English
language books in print, plus an
additional 50 million
international copies in print in
24 different languages.
The "Goosebumps" series made
R.L.
Stine a worldwide publishing
celebrity.
His other POB
popular series, mostly ghostly,
the
nightmare room, and rotten
school, it's
the first day of school forever,
a
midnight scream, young Scrooge,
and two picture books
illustrated by mark brown,
the little shop of monsters and
Mary Mcscary.
His books have also inspired
movies and TV series.  The
"Goosebumps" TV show was number
one for three years, and
episodes can still be seen on
streaming services.
And the feature film
"Goosebumps", BAZ based on his
book series was released in
2015.
The sequel, "Goosebumps" 2,
haunted
Halloween, will be released in a
few weeks.
He and his is here with us
today. Please join me in
welcoming R.L.
Stine
2: Haunted Halloween", will be
released in a few weeks. He is
here with us today. Please join
me in welcoming R.L. Stine.
[ Organ music ].
È R.L.
STINE: You put me near Slappy.
È LEE ANN POTTER: He scares
me a little bit.
È R.L.
STINE: Slappy is evil. I don't
like sitting next to it. How
nice to be here today. How many
of you have ever read a
"Goosebumps" book? Oh my
goodness! Thank you.
Thank you.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Quite a
few.
È R.L. STINE: And how many of
you saw the
"Goosebumps" movie with Jack
Black playing me.
Jack and I are like twins, don't
you think? What do you think?
Not quite. Not quite.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Fabulous.
I've got a very important
question for you. In with the
exchanges that we have been
having with colleagues about
this program, I was asking how
could I introduce you?
Do I call him R.L.? Robert? Mr.
Stine?
And someone said Bob.
È R.L. STINE: No one ever
called me R.L. all my life. I
used to be funny. I wrote joke
books for a long time. You want
to hear one of my best jokes?
Want to hear a joke? It's a kids
joke.  What do you get when you
cross a dog with a frog?
You get a dog that can lick
himself from across the room.
See? Now I made a living with
jokes like
that, and I -- yeah. All right.
All right.
It was -- I was known as jovial
Bob Stine. And then I got scary,
and I started writing scary
books, and I thought that jovial
Bob Stine? That's a horrible
name for a horror writer, right?
So I just used my initials.
And people always say -- kids
always say, what does R.L. stand
for?
And they pick something scary
.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I think it's
great. Yeah. Just a little bit.
So, I'm glad you mentioned that
you wrote jokes, because I read
that when
you were about 9 years old, at
the age of some of our students
in the audience,
that you found a typewriter in a
storage
room and started writing jokes
?
È R.L. STINE: My parents
didn't understand it at all. My
mother would stand outside of my
door and say, "What's wrong with
you? Go outside and play! Go
outside!
And I would say it's boring out
there." And type type type type
type. I have been doing that
ever since.
È RACHEL WILLIAMS: I think
È LEE ANN POTTER: I think
it's great. Here at the library
of congress, this is the largest
library in the world. We go into
the card catalog and try to get
a sense of how many books has a
particular author written, and
we're used to seeing a handful.
When we did a search on R.L.
Stine, we found hundreds of
titles.  We're curious: Where do
all of your identities come
from?
È R.L. STINE: I don't know.
Where do they come from? We all
get ideas, right? I don't know.
I would tell you, how many of
you have
read "The Haunted Mask," or seen
the TV show? That's a Halloween
story.
It's about a girl named Carly
Bets, who wants to be scary at
Halloween time.
And she tries on a scary mask,
and it sticks to her face, and
she can't get it off.
And it becomes her face, and it
turns her evil. And I will tell
you where the idea came from for
that story. It actually came
from my son, Matt, when he was a
little guy.
It was Halloween, and I was
watching Matt.
He was down on the floor trying
on a green rubber Frankenstein
mask. And he pulled it down over
his head, and he couldn't get it
off. And I'm watching from the
doorway. And he's down there,
and he's tugging and he's
tugging. And I thought, what a
great idea! I should have helped
him, right? Instead, I went and
started making notes and saying
oh, great idea for a story.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Perfect.
È R.L. STINE: And poor Matt
is still in the mask. It's a
very sad story.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I love it.
È R.L. STINE: You never know
where you're going to get ideas.
One day I was walking my dog in
the
park, and these words popped
into my
head: Say cheese and die. Why
those words? I started thinking,
well, what if there's an evil
camera? What if some kids
discovered the camera? And what
if the camera took pictures of
bad things that happened to you
a little bit in the future?
And that's how that book, "Say
Cheese
and Die" got started is from
those words popping into my
head. You never know where ideas
are going to come from.
È LEE ANN POTTER: When you have
a unique idea, I mentioned that
the library of congress is the
largest library in the world.
We're also home to the U.S.
copyright office. Have you heard
that word before? So you have an
idea, when you write a
book, one of the things that
you're encouraged to do is
submit that book to the U.S.
copyright office so that you
receive -- you own a copyright
on your work.
That means your ideas are yours
and your ideas are protected.
When we did a search on all of
the titles in our collection, we
asked our colleagues if they
would send over to our office a
bunch of them.  So we have about
10% of the books that are in the
library of congress that you
wrote with us today.
And many of these books were
submitted
when the copyright was
requested.
È R.L. STINE: Uh-huh.
È LEE ANN POTTER: And we
contacted
our colleague in the copyright
office, and we said Hey, we
don't suppose you have the
copyright registration forms for
all of the hundreds of books
that Mr. Stine has written, and
he responded through an e-mail,
and he was like of course we do.
We're the U.S. copyright office.
I went by his office yesterday,
and we have a gift for you.
È R.L. STINE: A gift?
È LEE ANN POTTER: Yeah. This is
an official copy of your very
first copyright registration
form for
the very first good "Goosebumps"
book. How about that?
È R.L. STINE: Wow!
[ Applause ]
That's amazing.
È LEE ANN POTTER: We thought
that was pretty note.
È R.L. STINE: That was
amazing.
The first one was "Welcome to
Deadhouse," and I think it was
the scariest book of them all. I
didn't know what I was doing. It
was the first one I wrote. It
didn't have the funny stuff. I
always like to do a book that's
scary and funny at the same
time, and this one is just
scary.
The second one, "Stay out of the
Basement," that had funny stuff
in it. I figured out what I was
doing. This is amazeing to see.
I have never seen any of this.
È LEE ANN POTTER: We put a
copy of it on the screen. It's a
two-page form. But we have lots
of them.
È R.L. STINE: I guess that's
a good thing.
È LEE ANN POTTER: It is a
good thing. When you wrote the
first "Goosebumps" book, did you
imagine that it would become a
series?
È R.L. STINE: When I wrote the
first one, I thought we would do
two or three. That was it. I
didn't know people would like
it. I wanted to be funny.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Yeah.
È R.L. STINE: And I didn't
understand it at all. And I used
to go to school, and I'd
say, "Why do you like these
books?" And kids would always
say we like to be scared. So, I
thought okay, forget the funny
stuff. I'll be scary from now
on.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Do you guys
like to be scared? BF
[ Audience answered affirmative
atively ].
[ Children chattering in the
audience ].
È R.L. STINE: I think that was a
yes or no question.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I think it got
am
bunk
ram crazy. It's almost
Halloween. Want to tell a story?
È R.L.
STINE: They took my podium away.
I'm going to stand up anyway and
see if I can come over here.
Nope. The light is terrible. And
I'm going to tell you -- let me
ask you a question first.
How many of you have ever seen a
ghost? How many? No, no. I mean
a real ghost. A real ghost. Not
on television.
Not in the movies
. Maybe I saw a ghost once. I
don't know. I'm going to tell
you. You can help me decide. I'm
going to tell you a true ghost
story that happened to my
brother Bill and me when we were
kids back in Ohio. It was
Halloween time, and Bill and I
were very excited, because it
was the first Halloween that we
were allowed to go out trick or
treating without our parents. We
were going out by ourselves for
the first time. And we both got
dressed as ghosts.
We put sheets down, and we cut
out eyes, and we were very scary
ghosts, and we got shopping
bags, big shopping bags
to collect all the candy.
And I took a can of that silly
string. You know that stuff?
You squeeze it and the string
comes out? Yeah.
Just in case we had to string
somebody. So, I tucked it in my
costume.  And Bill and I went
outside. It was a cold October
night.
I remember it was the kind of
cold that clings to the back of
your neck.
The ground was all crunchy, hard
from the frost. There was a tiny
sliver of the moon half covered
in cloud high in the sky.  And
Bill and I, we always started
out trick or treating at Mrs.
Dawson's house across the
street. And that was just our
tradition. We always started
there. But now I looked across
the street, and her house was
completely dark.
I said, "I guess she's not home,
Bill. We'll have to go on
without her." So we started at
the next house. We started trick
or treating down the block. And
my family was very poor.
We lived in a tiny little house.
There were blocks of very tiny
houses, which was great at
Halloween time, because it meant
you didn't have to go up any
long driveways.  You didn't have
any long walks.  You could just
go from house to house.
So Bill and I, we went three or
four blocks down, and then we
went three or four blocks and
came back. And by the time we
came back, our bags were just
bulging with candy. And I looked
across the street, and I saw a
light on in Mrs. Dawson's front
window.
I said "Bill, I guess she's
back. Let's go over there.
" As we went up her driveway, I
could see it wasn't a light.
It was a big Jack-o-lantern with
a big grin on its face and
yellow fire inside it. We got on
Mrs. Dawson's front stoop, and I
knocked on the door, and we
waited. She didn't come. So, I
knocked again, and I rang the
bell.
She didn't come to the door.
Bill said, "She's in there, Bob.
Go ahead. String her." So I took
out the silly string, and I
raised it to her door, and then
I stopped.
I stopped, and I froze, because
I saw
the Jack-o-lantern in the front
window had changed. It wasn't
yellow anymore. It was a bright
scarlet red, and it had
a big frown on its face
.
A big scowl. We were half way
down the driveway when the front
door swung open, and Mrs. Dawson
came out. I remember she was in
this gray
nightgown, this long, gray
nightgown.
I remember it fluttering in the
wind, fluttering.
And she said, "Why did you wake
me? Why did you wake me?
" And I said, "Oh, I'm sorry,
Mrs. Dawson. I didn't know. I'm
really sorry. But can I ask you
one question?
How did you do that with your
Jack-o-lantern?
" And she said, "Jack-o-lantern?
I don't have a Jack-o-lantern.
" And Bill and I looked in the
window, and it was completely
dark. Nothing was there. We ran
across the street, dumped out
all the candy, divided it all
up, and we never mentioned it
again.
We didn't mention the
Jack-o-lantern. We didn't say a
thing about it.
The next morning, I woke up
and I thought, you know what? I
should apologize to Mrs. Dawson.
We woke her up. That wasn't
right.
So, I got dressed for school,
had breakfast, and went across
the street to apologize, but
there was a big truck in Mrs.
Dawson's driveway, and these men
going in and out of her house.
And I went up to one of the
workers, and I said, "What's
going on?". He said I guess
you're getting new neighbors,
kid. I said "Why? What do you
mean?
" He said, "Oh, I'm sorry.
Didn't you hear? Mrs.
Dawson died two weeks ago."
That's my true ghost story.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
È LEE ANN POTTER: I think
they liked that story.
È R.L. STINE: Do you think maybe
I made up part of that true
story?
È AUDIENCE: Yes!
È R.L. STINE: Do you think I
made up a lot of that true
story? Maybe. I don't know.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I love it!
So, I know that we all enjoy the
titles of your books. And you've
named a few of them. Do you have
any favorites?
È R.L. STINE: A few favorite
titles?
One of my favorite titles is
"Little
Shop of Hamsters." It's totally
ridiculous.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Okay. Okay.
È R.L.
STINE: My favorite book is the
haunted mask. I think that's my
best Halloween story. And I
always -- I like all the books
with Slappy, because -- and I've
written a lot of them.
The new "Goosebumps" are called
goose bumps, slappy's world.
I love writing him because he
insults everybody.
He's very rude, and THAES that's
fun to write.
È LEE ANN POTTER: How do you
come up with titles?
È R.L. STINE: They come to me.
That's all I do. Kids don't care
about this. I don't even try to
come up with ideas anymore,
because I've done every story a
person can do. I just try to
think of titles. I'm doing a lot
of Slappy books, because he's so
popular.
And Slappy is the star of Goose
bumps 2.
And Slappy is incredible in the
new movie.
The newest "Goosebumps" book, I
had a
title "The Ghost of Slappy." I
killed him, but of course he
comes back.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Yep. Yep. I
understand sometimes you play
games with students where you
give us a quiz,
whether it's a real or fake
title? Should we play that?
È R.L. STINE: Let's do this.
Let's see how much you really
know about "Goosebumps"s, okay?
This is a list of "Goosebumps"
titles.  Some of them are real;
some of them are fake. Let's see
if you can tell which ones are
real and which ones are fake,
okay? Just shout it out. Shout
out fake or real. Okay? Here we
go.
One, son of slappy.
È real
!
È R.L. STINE: You're right.
Number two. You just have to
shout it once, and
we'll be fine.
Frosty the abombable snow man.
That's fake.
Number three, the barking ghost.
You got it! You guys are good.
Yeah that's real. How about this
one?
More Rons from marsons from
mars? That is fake, but I think
that would make a great
"Goosebumps" title. Morons from
Mars.  I sent that title to my
editors, and I
said let's do a "Goosebumps"
called
"Morons from mars," and they
said I
can't do that because I might
offend the morons.
Let's try number five, "It Came
from my Nose." That one's fake.
That one's fake.
È LEE ANN POTTER: That's a
good one, too.
È R.L.
STINE: Creature teacher. That
one's real! That one's real.
Attack of the 2,000
pound Datson?
How about eat Eat your
Breakfast? That's fake, too, but
that would be a good title. I
think that's scary, somebody
eating your breakfast. I think
it would be.
And how about, I am slappy's
evil twin? That one's real. That
one's real. You guys are good!
È LEE ANN POTTER: I love it.
È R.L.
STINE: You guys are scary.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Book titles
do certainly give us a sense of
a book's content. But sometimes
it helps to have a little bit
more of a description of a book
when you're deciding if it's a
book you want to read or not.
So, you guys know when you go to
a library, and you look at your
card catalog, not only do you
get the title
of a book, but you also get a
description of the book that
you're considering reading.
Well, those descriptions are
often
written right here at the
library of congress.
We have a group of colleagues
who work in the building next
door to this building, in our
Madison building, who are part
of the library's cataloging
division. And part of their job
is to read books and then write
descriptions of those books that
end up in the card catalog. And
one of our colleagues who does
that, her name is Anne, and
she's here, too.
I sent her a note and asked if
she remembers writing summaries
for any of R.L. Stine's books,
and she immediately responded
and said of course, and she gave
me a list of a bunch of them.
So, I'm going to read you a
couple of them.  One of the
books that you already
mentioned, "Welcome to Dead
house." Ann's the one who wrote
the summary for that book that
appears in the card catalog.
It reads "Amanda and Josh move
with their parents into an old
haunted house located in the
strange town of dark falls where
people are unlike any they have
known before." Do you think it
would be hard to capture an
entire book in less than 30
words?
È R.L. STINE: That's pretty
good for two sentences.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Here's
another one.
The title of the book is "Why
I'm afraid of Bees.
" Garrett's dream is about to
come true. He's going to
exchange bodies with another kid
for a whole week. But the new
body isn't human...
. that's a pretty good
description, too.
È R.L. STINE: It's a bee.
Where's that part?
È LEE ANN POTTER: The title gave
that one away.
È R.L. STINE: And a night in the
beehive.
HiHe sleeps in a beehive all
night. I would hate that.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I don't think
I would like it either. Might
you like to read a little from
one of your books?
È R.L. STINE: I could read
something.
I thought I would read you --
since
we're here, I might as well, you
know?
This is the very first chapter
of the
first "Goosebumps" slappy's
world book.
It's "Slappy Birthday to You."
This is just how the book starts
out.
It has a really weird and stupid
chapter ending.
So, that's why I like to read
it.
On Ian Barker's 12th birthday,
he received a gift that brought
pain and
terror to him and his entire
family.
But let's not get ahead of
ourselves.
Let's try to enJOIjoy Ian's
birthday for as long as we can.
Let's keep in mind that it was
not the birthday Ian had hopped
for.
It quickly became a day he would
have given anything to forget.
Ian came down to breakfast
on that sunny spring morning
eager for his special day to
begin. Almost at once, he had
trouble with his
-year-old  9-year-old sister,
molly, but that was nothing new.
If you asked Ian how to spell
molly, he
would say TROUBLE. There were
pancakes on the table.
Molly liked her pancakes drowned
in maple syrup, and she used up
most of the syrup before Ian had
a chance, but Ian didn't claim.
He was -- complain. He was
determined to be cheerful on his
birthday.
Then it came down to the last
pancake. Mine, Ian said.  You've
already had six.
But I saw it first, Molly
insisted.
She kept her fork poking into
the side of the pancake. It's my
birthday. I should get what I
want today. You always think you
should get what you want, molly
declared.
Molly has red hair and blue
eyes, and
when she gets into an argument,
her
freckled cheeks turn bright
pink. Her mom turned from the
kitchen counter.
She had been arranging cup cakes
for Ian's party. Fighting again?
We're not fighting, we're
disputing.
Oh, big word, Ian said. I'm so
totally impressed. They kept
their forks in the last
remaining pancake. You're a
jerk, molly said.  I know you
know that word.
Don't call Ian names on his
birthday, Mrs. Barker said. Wait
until tomorrow. She had a good
sense of humor.
Sometimes the kids appreciated
it. Sometimes they didn't.
Why don't you split the pancake
in two. Good idea, Ian said.  He
used his fork to divide the
pancake into two pieces.  No
fair, molly cried.  Your half is
twice as big as mine.
Ian laughed and gobbled up his
half before molly could do
anything about it. Molly frowned
about it.
Don't you know how to eat? You
have syrup on your chin. Ian
raised the bottle. How would you
like it in your hair? Whoa.
Mrs.
Barker turned away from the cup
cakes and stepped to the table.
Breakfast is other over. You're
12 now. You really have to stop
the fighting. She squeezed Ian's
shoulder. Your cousins are
coming for your party.
I want you to be extra nice to
them and don't pick fights like
you always do. Benny and Johnny?
They always start it.
Ian always starts it, molly
chimed in. Shut up, Ian chimed.
Just listen to me, Mrs. Barker
pleaded. I want you to be nice
to your cousins.  They have been
going through a rough time.
Uncle Donny is out of work and
aunt Marie is getting over the
operation. Can I have a cup cake
now? Ian slapped the table.
If she has one, I want one, too.
Have you heard a word I said,
Mrs. Barker asked?
And Ian raised his right hand as
if he were swearing an oath.
Hands off, Mrs. Barker said. Go
get your dad. Tell him guests
will be arriving soon. Where is
he? In his workshop, his mom
answered. Where else?
Where else, molly mimicked. Ian
walked down the back hall to the
door to the basement. He thought
about Johnny and Vinny.
They lived just a few blocks
away.
Johnny was 12 and Vinny was 11,
but they looked like twins.
They were both big bruisers,
tough guys, big for their eyes.
Loud and GRAP grabby with round
heads and upturned pig noses. At
least that's how Ian describes
them. The kind of guys that were
always bumping up against people
and each other and always
grinning about something mean,
mean guys.  They're just jealous
of you. That's what Mrs. Barker
always told Ian. They're your
only cousins, so you have to be
nice to them.
Ian opened the basement door and
went
down the stairs two at a time.
The air grew warmer, and it
smelled of GLU glue.
His father stood hunches over
his long work table. He turned.
Hi, Ian.
Hey dad, Ian started, mom says
-- her's a birthday surprise for
you, Mr. Barker said.
He reached both hands to his
face, plucked out his eyes and
held them up to Ian. That's
chapter one. You like that
ending?
È LEE ANN POTTER: I love it.
È R.L. STINE: Plucked out the
eyes? Come on.
È LEE ANN POTTER: That's
fabulous!
So you mentioned slappy?
È R.L. STINE: I know. I know.
Those may be fake eyes, you
know?
Ian's father is a doll repair
man. Yeah.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Later in that
boom
-- book, we learn more about
Slappy,
who plays a starring role in an
upcoming film.
È R.L.
STINE: Not "an" up coming film,
but
Goosebumps 2; haunted Halloween.
È LEE ANN POTTER: What is it
like --
È R.L. STINE: What is it like
to be a character in a movie? To
have somebody playing you? Like
Jack Black? It's a weird thing.
I sit there, and they're talking
about me in the movie. It's very
strange.
I had a great time. Jack Black
is a terrific guy. I'm so happy
he plays me.
We had a lot of fun together.
And I went down, actually -- I
had my 5 second cameo in my
first film. I went down and I
shot it. We were in a school,
and I walk out,
and Jack's there, and I say,
"Hello, Mr. Stine." That's my
line.
And he says, "Hello, Mr. Black.
" That was my five seconds in
the movie. Guess how many times
they shot it? Guess how many?
È LEE ANN POTTER: Three?
È R.L. STINE: 25. They shot it
25 times! I couldn't believe it.
And I was hungry. It was
lunchtime. I wanted to go get
lunch, and they kept shooting
the scene over and other again.
So, I might be in the next one.
I might be in the new one.
È LEE ANN POTTER: So we should
look for you?
È R.L. STINE: Look for me at the
very end of the film, the very
end.
And Slappy, in this one, it's a
Halloween movie. It's Halloween
time.
And Slappy, in his evil way,
decides to
bring everything Halloween to
life.
He goes into a drugstore, and he
brings all the masks to life and
all the Halloween toys and all
the costumes and
all the witch's hats and all the
creatures. And everything comes
to life.
It's an amazing scene at the end
of the new movie. Just all of
Halloween everywhere.
And I have to warn you that the
scariest scene involves gummy
bears. This is my favorite. I
know, they're cute, right? You
think they're cute...
but in this movie, it's not too
cute when gummy bears attack.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Yeah. Yeah.
È R.L. STINE: It's really
pretty incredible. That's my
favorite thing in the whole
movie.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Great.
È R.L. STINE: So I hope everyone
goes, a week
from Friday.
"Goosebumps" 2 haunted
Halloween.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I have a hunch
that some students in the
audience might have questions as
well.
È R.L. STINE: That would be
good.  We won't be able to hear
them.
È LEE ANN POTTER: We have
three microphones stationed in
different parts of our theater.
È R.L. STINE: Nice.
È LEE ANN POTTER: And our
colleagues, Sasha and Colena
have a couple. And they are
going to be asking students in
their little quadrants of the
theater if they have questions.
So, students, if you have a
question,
do raise your hand, and let one
of my friends with the
microphones call on you, and
when you ask your question, if
you would start by saying your
name, and then ask your
question, and the rest of us
will listen. And we also have
the opportunity for those of you
who are watching our programs on
the live stream, if you also
have questions that you want to
ask
, you can go on twitter and use
the
hashtag HTH
#goosebumps, and your questions
can be answered as well. So, how
about you find someone with a
question?
Who has a question
?
È tell us your name and the
question?
È my name is Chris, and my
question is how old were you
when you made your first book?
È R.L.
STINE: How old was I when I made
my first book?
The first book I ever had
published was called "How to be
Funny.
" It was how to be funny in
school and
how to get big laughs at the
dinner table. Parents hated this
book. They hated it. And I was
28.
È LEE ANN POTTER: 28. Great.
È R.L.
STINE: I was 9 when I started
writing,
but I was 28 when I had my first
book published.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Excellent
question. Sasha, how about you?
È SYDNEY ANDERSON:
È a question from online, from
my son, what was the hardest
book for you to write?
And what was the easiest?
È R.L.
STINE: They're all pretty easy
for me
. I write ten pages every day,
and I never have trouble. I can
always write my ten pages a day.
There was a "Goosebumps" book
called "Cry of the Cat" that I
had to write three times. Nobody
liked it. That happens. Once in
a while, that happens where I
write a book and none of my
editors like it. And they send
it back.
È who are your favorite
characters in your "Goosebumps"
movies and why?
È R.L. STINE: Well, I really
enjoy myself.
[ Laughter ]
I like Jack Black. Don't clap
for that! It's all new kids and
a new family. And the three kids
in the movie, I think you will
like them. And I think maybe you
will recognize
some of them, the boy from "It,"
he's in the film. Yeah. And I --
they are just wonderful. They're
a great part of the film.
I think you'll like them.
È My name is Sophia, and my
question
is who is your favorite evil
person from goose"Goosebumps"
and why?
È R.L.
STINE: Here's my favorite
monster, how
many of you saw "Welcome to Camp
Jelly Jam.".
" Jelly jam is a huge BLOP blob.
This is my smelly book.
He smells so bad, he has to be
bathed 24 hours a day.
So, all the campers that come to
his camp, that's what they do.
They bathe him all day long and
all night. And then finally, I'm
going to spoil the ending for
you. They get -- yeah. I am.
I'm going to.
They decide they've had it with
him. It's enough. And they stop
bathing him, and he dies from
his own smell.
[ Laughter ]
That's my favorite. I love
him. I love him.
È LEE ANN POTTER:
Up there.
È what was your favorite and
least favorite books you have
written?
È R.L. STINE: These are hard
questions.
There's a fairly recent one
called
"Attack of the Jack," and it's
about Jack-o-lanterns that come
to life.
But I really like this book
because
there's a talking cat in it.
There's a talking cat in the
book, and I can't believe they
let me get away with that. So,
that's one of my favorites. Then
there's some that are, you know,
I don't really like that much. I
shouldn't talk about this.
But there's a "Goosebumps" book
called the barking ghost that I
don't think is
very good
.
È After the second "Goosebumps"
movie, will you make a third
one?
È R.L. STINE: If everyone comes
to this one, I think they'll
want to make another one, right?
If people don't go, I think
that'll be it. One and two. You
never know.
I would love to do more movies.
È We have a question on Twitter.
What is the greatest piece of
advice you would give to an
author just starting out?
È R.L. STINE: The best advice I
would give, I never give advice.
I never give advice, because I
always think people who are
going to become authors and
really want to be authors
are like me, and they just write
all the time. They're always
writing. And you don't have to
show them why don't you write.
You don't have to tell them to
read a lot, because they do. I
always think they're like me,
and they don't need advice. They
just want to keep writing and
writing and getting better.
So, I never give advice.
È My name's Theo, and my
question is, what is your
favorite scene in the
original goose BUMPGS -- goose
goose
"Goosebumps" movie?
È When they are on top of the
Ferris wheel sitting and talking
together? I think that's a
really sweet scene. And I love
that scene. I just think they
are so terrific. That's my
favorite scene in the first
movie.
È LEE ANN POTTER: That's a great
question.
È R.L. STINE: I have never been
asked that question. That's a
first.
È My name is terra.
If you made a new goose
"Goosebumps" book, what would it
be?
È R.L.
STINE: I just started a
"Goosebumps"
book called "The Dummy meets the
Mummy.
" You can kind of GETSS guess
what that's about, right?
È LEE ANN POTTER: I like that
sneak peak.
È My name is Bryce, and my
question is,
how did you invent Slappy, and
why is it so popular?
È R.L. STINE: That's a good
question. That, I couldn't
answer.
When I was a kid, I loved
puppets, and
I had mare owe
puppets and would do shows and
things.
I WUDS was always interested.
Here's a terrifying story.
When I was really little, I was
so little that I still had to
take a nap.
And my mother would read a
chapter of a
book to me before my nap every
day
. I'm this tiny guy, and for
some reason
, she chose to read the original
PI NOEK
Pinniocchio to me. He's a wooden
puppet.
He falls asleep with his feet on
the
stove, and he PURN burns his
feet off. I never forgot that.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I wonder if
your nap was good that day.
È R.L. STINE: I don't know if my
nap was good or not that day.
I never forgot that and I have
always been interested in
puppets, and I think that's how
Slappy came to be.
It's funny how much Slappy looks
like Jack Black these days.
He's kind of changed, huh?
Time nor for a couple more?
È How about this one right here?
È R.L. STINE: Who has a really
good question?
È
My name is Stacey, and what's
your favorite part of a book out
of all of
your books
?
È R.L. STINE: I like the ending.
It means I'm done.
I like the ending. Who has a
really good question?
È Sasha, in the back?
È My name is phoenix, and I was
wondering, what inspired you to
create "Goosebumps"?
È R.L. STINE: To do the book
series? Is that the question? I
was doing a series for teens.
I was doing a scary book series
for teenagers, which I'm still
doing called "Fear Street.
" It was teens in terror and
horrible things happening to
anybody who moved to Fear
Street.
And my editors came to me and
said, Why
don't we do a scary book series
for younger kids, and I of
course said no.
I didn't want to do
"Goosebumps". That's the kind of
business man I am, right? And
they said no. No one has done
it. Let's try it. Let's try it.
And so I said okay. If I can
think of a good name for the
series, then maybe we can try a
couple.
And one day I was reading TV
Guide.
In those days, it had the
program listings in the middle
of the magazine. It told you
what was on TV. And I'm going
through the magazine, and
there was a tiny ad at the
bottom of the
page, and it said "It's goose
bumps week
on channel 11," and I stared at
it and thought that's perfect.
We'll call it channel 11. That's
a bad joke. I apologize. That's
a very bad joke.
But that's where the name good
"Goosebumps"s came from.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I think one
more question, and we're good.
È We have one back here.
È R.L. STINE: One more. All
right.
È My name is Travis, and my
question
is, the new movie "Goosebumps"
from the new characters?
È R.L. STINE: Say it again?
È From the new goose bumps
movie, are
you going to make the book from
the new
characters in the goose bumps
movie?
È R.L. STINE: Yeah, well there
are two books out about the new
movie. And they are both telling
the story with the new
characters and everything. All
new characters. Yeah.
There are two books.
È RACHEL WILLIAMS: We have a
final question from our friends
watching online.
È My daughter's only 8 months
old, so
she has a little time before we
get to
"Goosebumps"s, but I remember
the
bookshelf where I picked up "the
Barking Ghost.
" So do you have recommendations
ifs for a costume based on your
books?
È R.L. STINE: She's eight months
old?
My grandson Dylan, when he was 2
-- he's 4 now.
When my grandson Dylan was 2
years old, he was going out for
Halloween as
Slappy, and I had Slappy in my
apartment. I had the dummy.
And Slappy's clothes fit my
grandson. They fit him
perfectly.
So, we took the clothes off the
dummy
and Dylan went out for Halloween
as Slappy wearing Slappy's
clothes. That's pretty good,
right?
È LEE ANN POTTER: Perfect.
È R.L. STINE: He never gave them
back. Poor Slappy doesn't have a
shirt or anything.
But I don't know about costumes
for an 8 month old.
È LEE ANN POTTER: This has been
so much fun.
È R.L. STINE: This has been
great. Thank you all so much.
Thank you!
[ Cheers and Applause ]
È R.L. STINE: You're perfect.
Thank you so much.
È LEE ANN POTTER: On behalf of
the
library ofLibrary of Congress,
Bob, R.L., Mr. Stine, thank you
so much for being here. Thank
you for responding to our
questions and thank you for all
that you've done to inspire so
many young readers.
And really, best of luck to you
and we are excited about your
new film.
È R.L. STINE: Thank you. What a
great morning. Thank you.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Thank you.
[ Applause ]